what kind of additional pressures come
or is there any additional pressures
when you're working with the director
like Tom Ford um no I don't mean for him
yeah it's the second movie I've made 40
so no but I didn't make them necessarily
but I've been in them but um there there
there really aren't you know I think my
only concern with him was that we you
know we always go for the truth and
honesty and behavior you know one of the
things about this movie in one of the
struggles I think he communicates that
he has is that struggle between
aesthetic and you know the way things
look and then how he feels and what his
heart says you know and so that's a
struggle for him and I just wanted to
make sure that if we were on set
together and there was a scene that was
happening something real was happening
he didn't he didn't think something look
pretty that he would let it keep going
because if he didn't it would have
really upset me you know and I tried to
make myself clear before we started that
you know my goal always is to get at
something real and to be honest I don't
really care how it looks
because I think how we feel is all that
really matters in the end and he totally
agreed you talk about something real
unlike theme obviously there's a couple
um but one of the most heartbreak and I
mean have you ever had your heart broken
and how does that kind of affect you
think as a person in terms of your
development I mean absolutely I mean I
think you I mean it depends like you
mean romantically professionally my
heart has been broken many many times I
think that's the only way you grow up I
think like you know heartbreak shame
those things are what teachers regret
those are the things that teach us
that's how we become the best people we
can become you know so if we listen to
them you know and in the case of this
story that's exactly what this character
does and I app I empathize with him 100%
in fact so much so it I'm been
embarrassed in that I've played so many
roles where I'm I think I'm
wish-fulfilling you know I'm like
playing a boxer or
I'm playing this like sociopathic guy
who knows who's five steps ahead of
everybody else and like has all the
power and in this case I think I'm
playing someone who's maybe a little
closer to my response in a situation
like he finds himself in I'm I think I
I'd have a hard time wouldn't know what
to do you know I I believe in
non-violence you know what I mean and I
I so and that was hard for me to face
you know that is interesting to to play
a character not totally like me but
close enough in sensitivity I think in
vulnerability that I had to face some
things about myself that maybe you know
I didn't think I liked and I learned how
to love within this process speaking of
which um it seems like there's a
bromance
speaking of heart maybe a bromance going
on with Ryan Reynolds he tweeted out by
today did you guys he tweeted what did
he tweet tweeted something about your
playa he tweeted I guess no way it's
like I thought it was great etc and then
obvious you guys did life together is
there is there a you guys formed
obviously a pretty good friendship yeah
you know what I mean um man it's there
are not a lot I mean he is a good man
act he's like a brother he became very
quickly like that like we just connected
you know I think you know I from afar
over this past year I've been in awe of
his creative success and um I just I
think he has with Deadpool in particular
I think he has allowed himself to to do
something that very few artists actually
do which is expressed in a huge medium
in a big format himself you know like
his humor all that stuff is no one could
do it like him and it was just I was
rooting for him from afar and then we
got to work together and um and I just
realized what a good what a good man he
is and so yeah he's he's a good friend
and I'm like I'm proud to say that he's
my really good friend he's a wonderful
man